this masterpiece by famous catalan
architect anthony gowdy has been under
construction for nearly 140 years
although unfinished the sagrada familia
is one of barcelona's biggest
attractions
many people in barcelona thought they'd
never live to see it completed
but it might finally happen on the
centenary of gowdy's death in 2026
it's beautiful it still has to be
finished but once they finish it it will
be even more beautiful we'll be able to
admire the beauty of the whole complex
weather can be finished on time will
depend on tourists like these
gowdy demanded that the entire project
be funded from ticket sales and private
donations but constant shortfalls have
stole the project longer than perhaps
even he imagined
the pandemic brought construction to a
halt we didn't have visitors for almost
a year without receiving funds we had
very little but the construction board
decided to keep going ahead
but now the sagrada familia is facing a
new challenge
finishing the main entrance will require
demolishing several nearby buildings
thousands of people could be evicted and
many don't want to move
our proposal both for the city hall and
the board of construction is that we are
very comfortable in our homes
we've paid for them and they are totally
legally ours
balancing the rights of residents
against a major architectural spectacle
for the city has put local authorities
in a difficult position
there aren't magical solutions here we
don't think that in order to finish the
basilica all buildings involved must be
demolished but we also think it isn't
likely that all buildings will be saved
we must see the different options and we
as local government with the neighbors
and the sagrada familia are working on
that
the project has been delayed many times
by the spanish civil war in the 1930s by
economic downturns and most recently by
the pandemic
gowdy died in 1926 and never expected
the sagrada familia to be finished in
his lifetime
referring to who he described as god he
was often known to say
my client is in no rush
vincent monaghan al jazeera